hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting
to a video from manis manosphere
highlights daily whatever that means
how much proof do you need psy
why men walk away before i start if you
guys want to support the channel
please subscribe trying to hit that 15
000
subscriber mark um
okay i don't know how much proof
do i need 13. because the person that is
for me
is going to take me right now at being a
little over 300 pounds
because then in the future when i look
at you
i can say you deserve me now at my best
because this isn't my best my best is
yet to come
but you should earn and deserve me at my
best
and that's the problem a lot of people
don't want to
put the work into people that don't
look like they're worth the work
[Music]
problem with that statement
they don't know you
i you can't expect people to put the
work into someone
they don't they don't know how much
proof do you need
i'm curious uh because i don't think
that question has ever been asked or
what are black women willing to do to
save the black community
nothing
okay
um i will say i think in a roundabout
way yeah it has and i'm still doing um i
still have my
my um facebook i still get get out
within the community
um black women aren't willing to do
anything
and i keep saying because they're able
to get certain types of validation
and they're able to make the money um
i here for what like why would i how
much proof do you need
i'm not saying we should have a special
victim status but our circumstance is
different we are women
we are 24 years old is your circle is
your circumstance
harder or easier than your grandmother
and your great-grandmother
exponentially easier we have access to
information
exponentially easier but you're handling
it worse
your grandmother your great-grandmother
actually could work with a black man
with more trauma
because they understood that the black
woman and the black man are on the same
side now that we are
all free and independent we could do
whatever we want to
why would we seek to you know
be one with the black man we think that
being thank you
thank you thank you clip it slice it put
it on worldstar she said it not me
how much proof do you need people to go
on social media as a woman
and you can post pictures and you can
get all the validation and attention you
need for
whatever that time frame is and you risk
and you repeat
um when you're not able to get the
attention on social on a certain form of
social
media you go to if you can't get it on
facebook you go to instagram you can't
go to instagram you go to twitter you
can't go to twitter you go to snapchat
after you do that after you do that and
let's say you still didn't get enough
attention
you can go to tinder you can go to
plenty of fish you can swipe right
and it's instant and then she's able to
have her
affirmative action job and she's still
able to make a certain amount of money
and drive whatever kind of car and live
she can be in debt
people act like if women are going
through a certain thing that they care
about these things like normal society
and that's just not the case they don't
care
how much proof do you need so i will say
one caveat obviously
the people that are gonna make the best
like highlights and most viewed videos
are gonna be the craziest
but i i do see a pattern i do see i'm
currently
not dating uh for the first time in for
like first time ever
i've always been dating always as in
like on
uh apps and stuff because you know i
don't like to be alone i like the
attention whenever i start to feel
insecure
i would go on the apps and have someone
call me pretty not
force them but you know like someone's
gonna call me pretty
and just feel good about myself like
okay i'm good now but you know
i want to get to a stage where i don't
need that how much
proof do you need i wish that
he was my boyfriend again i don't
necessarily want to be single
but i miss the single life
i miss the text messages for no reason
i miss the coming up from behind me when
i'm scrambling eggs and just kissing me
on the back of the neck
like i still do that boris i still do
that
[Music]
how much proof do you need the trappings
of being
single like okay you two are really
good-looking people
okay and you're married and and and
we're married
there's people that flirt with you and
the part of the flirtation
doesn't make you necessarily go wayward
really go
wayward but part of the flirtation that
even makes you look at your phone
is for in your in your workspace is that
they have like a freshness or a newness
and i personally believe
that if you're in it for the long haul
that freshness and newness is still
possible if you talk about it be like
look
i know we talk about like kissing and
texting for no reason but the last time
you text me was over
like you know look at that guy's face
like look at him he's
not he's like shut up shut up shut up
the cabinet guy how much peru
do you need i envisioned the type of man
i wanted i prayed for the type of man i
wanted
and i got pretty much that is he perfect
absolutely not but
you know he has a lot of the qualities
no
he has a lot of qualities that uh that i
love and we're having a really good time
and i'm enjoying life so there is hope
women
lady that's not
i don't think that was that bad she said
he's not perfect
is that that bad guys let me know what
spruce do you need
women do complain now my husband's
always on me why is he always on me
if sex is gonna be a chore for you that
you don't really want to do
why do women constantly push monogamy
on men if you know that you don't want
to have to deal with him all the time
just wanting you
why do you push monogamy on that well
who's to say i pushed anything on
anybody
like well we know that you pushed
monogamy on me i pushed men out of you
i forced you to get married to me
timeout i didn't say you forced me to
get married but
did you not say to me that you wanted to
be engaged and you wanted to be married
before you lived with me you didn't say
that i want a billion dollars i don't
mean i'm going to get it
i can want something but not you right
now you're dodging the point nobody
pressed you to do it yes is that
something i wanted yes it was
but you didn't impress me are you going
to lie now to the people because we're
talking about sex
you're going to lie now to the people
knowing
you didn't want monogamy of course i did
so then why are you avoiding the
question that's not avoiding the
question i'm saying does that mean
because i want it and i requested that
that you were going to deliver it like
nobody pressed you for that
tomorrow you just said you wanted it and
requested it do you not hear yourself
i can make a request is the request
going to be granted
am i not am i i think i'm just reading
between the lines i think she's saying
that i i didn't force you to do anything
this was what i wanted but you didn't
have to do it but she's
saying it very like like obviously her
feelings are hurt because
basically he's saying you're like
forcing me to be monogamous
i'm not granting you monogamy you are
granting it to so
how much proof do you need this is my
question if you wanted monogamy
okay why would you want monogamy if
monogamy
if if sex is a chore for you that's the
question you're avoiding the questions
i'm not avoiding the question but at
first you said
me women or or in general me
specifically are pushing
monogamy on somebody okay yes that's
something that i wanted
but i didn't press you for it and be
like developing a whole a gunshot wound
you had to propose to me
so also let me finish also
i don't feel like i was adequately
prepared for marriage and i've said that
before because
if i knew that marriage and monogamy was
going to involve me
trying to meet you where you were at
sexually for years to come
then i probably would have reevaluated
it if i wanted to be monogamous anyway
how much proof
uh
something that really bothers me and
like honestly has given me a sense of a
little bit of an insecurity
is the fact that yeah like there are all
these women like throwing themselves
but me like the past 10 years like
i don't have any of that like i have
zero
this sounds weird but like male
attention
and so then like i begin to internalize
it and i'm like is something wrong with
you you're not
you're not looking like you're not even
but i'm gonna tell you something else
too
when your radar's turned off because
i've dealt with that for years too like
and i was young like you
yeah i'm like that's nice because i
don't want it but
it'd be nice to know that like someone's
looking
right i think the real insecurity comes
from the fact
that her husband has like women
from like like
it's gonna sound so bad but her husband
has like
better options than she does
and so it makes her feel like
don't less think for one minute that
they know some men out there looking at
you like i wish
honestly and i'm gonna tell you and she
is she's like
still very pretty who knows that more
than anybody
yeah your husband
you mean will smith how much proof do
you need
yeah and then i got into an entanglement
with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship
oh my gosh i forgot about this this was
the most cringe absolutely how much
proof do you need
what do you feel like um
you were looking for i just wanted to
feel good it had been so
long since i felt
good oh how much proof do you need
that being said if you are broke and i
choose to deal with you
i will belittle you it is what it is
and i reserve the right to do that how
much proof do you need
i care about what's in this contract
with black america for women and it's
not we're not mentioned at all in the
contract with black america
i mean when you when you mention black
people you mentioned in black women so
don't count yourself out that's not true
it's like administration
black women are not included in black
people now
of course black women are included in
black how much proof do you need
she definitely i think that testing
needs to be mandatory
it's like wow this should be meaningful
because
if you're not swinging your dick around
i think that the united states making
dna testing mandatory is stupid
i don't think that you know
it's something that if you feel like you
need a dna test go do that on your own
time
because you feel that way i don't think
every person there's millions of people
in the united states like it doesn't
make sense that people could be using
that time to do other things like
you could be saving a life you could be
in a hospital saving a life
huh it's actually not a bad idea
i heard there is i don't know if this
study was real or not but i heard
somewhere that there was a study
that 10 of this like small town
they like wanted to see like how bad
infidelity was and 10
of the kids were raised by parents that
weren't theirs like unknowingly
obviously how much proof do you need so
this is what i'ma say
i think that y'all
want this to be mandated because of a
conversation
you are not strong enough to have with
your girl
one two you
requesting dna first of all this is a
very gendered question right there's no
way for a woman
well let me not speak for every woman
for me specifically there's no way if my
man came up to me i wouldn't feel some
type of offense
but fine if you have you have the right
to know whether it's your child or not
because i know this is my child right
but to say that it's mandated is where i
have a problem
who who was picking up those costs the
u.s government
the us government should be paying for
these mandatory tests
for you to know no no because no first
of all we have
so many issues in this country already
to fact to
to then place that type of payment
on the us government no no
no first of all
healthcare doesn't does not cover so
many
ailments that are like people are dying
from is it gonna cost
that much to get dna tested let me know
in the comments
it's not it's not even just ailments
like just like just
just feminine products so for you to
make that mandatory that would have to
be a government issue
if you want a mandatory test which i do
you
pay for it again i got the money for it
but i actually kind of agree i don't
really care
either way but
like why should taxpayers have to pay
for that
why can't you just do it if you need one
make it clear because let me finish my
sentence all right go ahead let me
finish my session
how much proof do you need i personally
pay taxes
and i care about where my money goes i'm
not here to pay
for so and so because there's a
confusion about who's the father that's
not my business
handle your your personal [ __ ]
and for me i want to fund schools i want
to fund
the mta because the trains are never on
time we got bigger problems
we have bigger problems i'm sorry i'm
not paying for no mandatory
tests how much proof do you need into
buying this building
into developing this concept so black
people can have somewhere nice to go to
okay
somewhere where we can feel good about
ourselves as a look
stop today please somewhere where our
people can feel good about ourselves as
a culture okay
yeah no no real talk and so all this
twerking and [ __ ]
taking the prime taking the pink don't
bring it here because we're a restaurant
and so beyond that
75 percent of my customers are ladies
and i'm not mean to show respect for
themselves for how they carry themselves
here
so how can i tell the men to respect
themselves and you guys are talking on
glass here if you want to do it you can
check out my restaurant
because i did it for our people and i
did it for our culture so don't do it
now don't do it again i don't want to
hear it if you don't like it
get out because i don't need your money
i need to provide something for my
people
don't do it again thank you
that's really true girls want to ask for
respect but they don't respect them
how much proof do you need you want
answers i want the truth
you can't handle the truth how much
proof do you need
i can do this all day so much more
evidence
store but in the evidence room
proof of what they just said proof do
you need
a white men walk away okay fair
like what was what was the proof that
there's crazy women out there
i know um okay let me know what you guys
think in the comments
don't forget to subscribe talk to you
guys next time